So if we were able to assume the discrete log is hard,
then we could prove that Diffie-Hellman is secure
if we could show that breaking Diffie-Hellman
implies that one can also solve the discrete log problem.
No one has been able to prove that.
Instead the security of Diffie-Hellman relies on a stronger assumption--
what's known as the Decisional Diffie-Hellman Assumption.
This is a little bit circular that we're basing the security argument for Diffie-Hellman
on an assumption that was invented because this is what Diffie-Hellman relies on.
That seems a bit circular, and indeed it is.
But it is a useful way of crystallizing what we really rely on
to know that the Diffie-Hellman protocol is secure.
And what we're relying on is this property that
G to the XY mod Q, and this is how we're computing the key
when the XY values--
one is a secret value, and one is the value that was sent in the previous message--
and the assumption is that this value, which is G to the XY mod Q,
and that's the value that's computed as the key in the Diffie-Hellman protocol,
is indistinguishable from random
even to an attacker who knows G, G to the X, G to the Y, and Q--
these are the messages that would be intercepted.
So if this assumption is true,
that would be enough to prove that the Diffie-Hellman protocol is secure,
and that an attacker who eavesdrops on all the messages can't compute the key
because what the assumption is stating is that there is no way that they could tell
that that value, which is the correct key, is any different from a random number
even when they have access to this information.
So this is an assumption, and it's even worse than that--
it's known that it's not true for certain values.
We can show that it is distinguishable from random.
So the security of the Diffie-Hellman protocol would follow from this assumption
if we knew this assumption were true.
We don't, but people have been trying for a long time to break Diffie-Hellman,
and so far it seems to be adequately secure.
That is certainly not enough to guarantee that it always will be.
Next we're going to talk about some issues in actually implementing Diffie-Hellman.